you ever do anything weird to the no but
my rider was put on what on online one
time and I got a lot of because it was a
because I don't need anything at my show
I mean it's you don't I mean as far as
you know crazy like the old stupid
advisors they put Brown M M's or
whatever yeah and the reason they did
that was because they wanted to read the
writer I think that's why the real
reason they did that I didn't know that
yeah so they would say brown m m so they
would see if they read it so they would
do oh
you know the brand M M's you didn't read
the writers so we did stupid
things like my crew wanted socks or
something I don't know a lot it was like
tube socks and
um I don't need you know some teens some
Crown Royal or something
other than that there was some other odd
things but it came online and people
would come to me like you're like like
the biggest diva in common is that
really your writer I'm like no it's just
it's like there's not a lot of things on
there like you have to you have to have
like tubes in my crib I don't need tube
socks I love it you go no it's not true
it's for my cruise they need me they I
they need tube socks I can perform
without socks I need lube for my
afterwards that's every single time they
need new tube socks yeah no it's a joke
no they don't no they do they have them
every night yeah they have tube socks
they have like 75 pairs of tube
socks yeah they want them no we don't
use them they just they're they're just
so they can see them
tea
[Music]